you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at another alpha zero game alpha zero
has white in this one again stockfish
eight and this is the only game of the
queen's indian defense games where
stockfish eight initially deploys the
Queen Bishop to a6 so let's see how play
develops starts off not looking like a
Queen's Indian but we quickly transpose
and it's on this move for where we see
Bishop a6 c4 struck out sensitive point
a couple approaches one to defend with a
piece two to defend with a pawn
defending with a pawn is not without its
weaknesses and defending with the knight
well White has no interest in
obstructing the bishop alpha zero opts
for Queen c2 development defense if
there's a downside connected with this
it's may be seen in that the Queen is no
longer observing some d-file squares
this is where black now strikes hitting
out a d4 hitting out the d4 point d5
ensues and with this well it's a gambit
line White's giving up a pawn for what
exactly what we'll see in just a bit a
couple captures first materials bounced
black doesn't win the pawn now AZ that
would lose on the spot actually Queenie
for not only is this check but the queen
is hitting both knight and rook save the
knight the rook is dead so the bishop
drops back to the main diagonal d5 is
now hit twice defended zero it cannot be
defended adequately it seems like you
play e4 and things are cool kind of shut
down the bishop but efore could be met
with Queen e7 this is a very nice double
attacking move what's the double attack
exactly
well ephors now hit twice and in a pin
and because of this pin we revisit this
same situation
that being d5 is now hit twice and
defended zero so if Knight c3 I can
simply take this is one of the many ways
black can by force win that pawn white
understands this and simply gets on at
this stage with King side development
doesn't bother trying to hang on to d5
Bishop g2 Knight takes d5 the fearless
piece takes d5 taking with the bishop
eventually allows development with tempo
don't want to allow the knight to take
the bishop so it's the knight that takes
on d5 King is no safe Queen side
development guaranteed productive move
rook d1 asking the knight a question it
doesn't respond
it doesn't need to Bishop e7 this Knight
is indirectly defended if rook takes
knight Knight B for hitting the Queen
once and in the rook twice so what do we
have in this position after Bishop to e7
well I have yet to touch on what is the
main idea behind this gambit well I
don't know if I could say main idea mmm
there if there's one key square that
white now has available as a result of
this gambit it is the f5 square there's
no longer an eponymous is a square that
is more often than not made use of by
the King Knight pivoting on h4 and
sinking into f5 however in this game
with this variation of Bishop a6 and
then returning to b7 trying to distract
the Queen away from seeing the D file
squares in a way I feel like alpha zero
is trying to demonstrate that this Queen
c2 move is actually a useful move and
this is where we have the White Queen
make use of the f5 square
this I just feel is such a wonderful
move on the surface most directly it
questions a strong post on d5 this night
needs to find a new home right now this
is a threat taking with the queen or
rook and it's a nice forward move
alright just doing a quick comparison
queen positions like queen is much more
active it's true there's still a lot of
traffic on board Queen has to proceed
with caution not getting trapped but
they'll be some squares on the King side
for the White Queen to operate on the
knight needs to find a new home it
decides on f6 but this is short-lived
we now have efore notice these guys are
still just hanging out on the Queen side
white is very quick to question this
Knight post all pieces remain on board
that's the other thing to maybe know you
know you could have maybe seen an early
night c3 and possibly a king night for a
queen Knight exchange but maybe white is
you know anticipating that you can
actually race this pawn all the way up
to e5 and cause some type of domino
effect influence the quality of the
black pieces have to find new squares to
to to pivot about on and in fact the
knight on f6 needs to find a new home
now
'if I've is right around the corner and
where will the Knights home be black has
h5 in mind that's why we have g6 at this
moment preparing to meet e5 Knight h5
but this is not without its weaknesses
f6 and h6 are vulnerable so the
drops back keeping a close eye on e4 and
a close eye on both weekend squares
before you could kind of make use of
weaknesses in your opponent's camp you
have to first observe them right so the
queen is observing both f6 and h6 and
soon well maybe she can make use of
those squares pivot on those squares
continuing we now have castles g5 on
board sure enough Knight h5 queen g4 now
I was just saying a moment ago you're
observing these squares next year you
know you're ready to then make use of
those squares
why isn't Queen h6 played here I believe
it's related to this Bishop to f8 move
it appears that that's like an under
developing move but really it's a it's a
it's a productive move this rook would
like to play to e8 and the bishop would
then like to play to FA it's a common
reorganization
it's a typical reorganization so that
the major pieces can have some influence
on the the e-file black can exert some
pressure against a 5 so placing the
Queen on h6 may kind of backfire runs
into you may you may want to view Bishop
f8 as a developing move with tempo in
this case okay in the game it's queen g4
observing d5 there's also a pin here I
don't know that you can really take
advantage of you know this pinch pawn
but okay couple things to know rook e8
Knight c3 and Queen to be eight so this
is actually a pretty interesting moment
after Queen Queen g4 rook to e8 this is
a moment where white can win this pawn
back could take on d7 with the rook but
alpha zero has no interest in simply
regaining the pond
why why is these games are so
interesting why why is maybe that not
why does white not go forward with this
you know there's still all pieces on the
board and black has created two serious
weaknesses in their camp and meanwhile
the White King has a very cozy home
secured by the bishop in the night can't
say the same about the black side it's a
little bit more vulnerable you know
Knights kind of on the on the edge here
the bishop is not on this g7 square not
as cozy a home for Team black taking on
d7 may eventually force the Queen's off
the board right rook takes Queen Bishop
takes Queen and there go the Queen's and
without the Queen's the king is not
nearly as vulnerable white doesn't want
to take the pawn doesn't want to just
regain the pawn because the Queen's I
believe will be off the board wants to
keep the powerful piece of board so
Knight c3 Queen be 895 it doesn't get
much much better than that right Knight
c3 95 fantastic square eyeing up a weak
point f6 Bishop is under fire as well
Bishop is saved Bishop f4 and with that
white is completing development well the
rooks are now connected he five is
secure this Queen doing a queen
comparison are really we're starting to
see the white pieces really drift
towards the Kings side right now these
are these minor pieces are really
swarming in towards the King we have a
lot of pieces just camping out on the
Queen side far away from helping defend
any of the King side squares Queen c8
and now we have this short little move
this small move Age
three securing the Queen one of the
ideas behind Queen CA is to exchange off
this half dead pawn for a super strong
pawn on e5 Lex idea is to play d6
threatening up in the exchange of D and
E pawns and also a queen exchange this
Queen is currently unprotected some
security now for white with h3 so if in
this position d6 we can take and there's
no fear of you know we don't have to
deal with this Queen takes Queen move
would be the better side here of d6 so
what is black do ninety seven now isn't
this night getting in the way of the
rook this Knight is also a second-rank
piece let's avoid that exchange the
knight drops back to a nice square this
is a much better post for the night when
compared to this guy in e7 keeps pieces
on the board when you have some space
continuing Bishop c6 lending some
support to d7 maybe right around this
point now that a few more moves have
been in there there is this threat to
simply regain the material and simply be
better
rook d6 in the game there are a lot of
weaknesses d 6f 6 h6 all dark squares
notice the pieces how they swarm into
these weak points night g7 rook f6
and in the game here we had Queen b7 if
the knight returned here there wouldn't
be anything better than the rook
returning back to d6 I I believe and I
don't know that we have some repetition
I believe there would be a bishop to h6
move eventually this happens in the game
right now exactly Queen b7 Bishop h6 95
so our first piece exchange unmoved 24
quite a bit took quite a bit for that to
happen and now we have rook to d1
getting the last piece involved
meanwhile
the rook on a a not really doing a whole
lot queen kind of specific to the queen
side a much more evasive pieces over
here continuing Knight to e6 the dark
square bishop SAR now gone and now white
finds it much easier to make use of
these weekend squares without that
master defender around so Queen h4 and
Bishop c6 Queen h6 rook e8 and here we
go got a lot of major pieces occupying
the weak points
all of them are occupying the weak
points in blacks camp there is a lot of
influence on seventh rank squares and
let's not forget this sixth rank as well
so I'm pressure against g6
some sacrifices are right around the
corner Bishop takes Knight in this
position what are these sacrifices I'm
talking about so just as an example it's
kind of making a passing move if in this
position the knight is not captured
let's say Queen c7 hasn't just a quick
example here's one of the sacrifices
that's available to white rook takes
knight removing a key defender of Knight
g5 so after pawn takes Knight g5
checkmate next he capture in another
direction it doesn't matter
it's three different ways you can
recapture here and all of them would be
met with Knight g5 so this move Knight
g5 once more no good way to defend this
point
d5 could be met with chop
chop a very nice sequence here picking
up the Queen
serious tactical opportunity here for
white this night needs to be removed and
is on this move 29 chop-chop an
imbalance is now present Bishop versus
Knight position
clean Asics this queen is now going to
get quite active striking at a two at
the moment
white doesn't care about those pawns
though queenside pawns are irrelevant
white is pursuing an attack against the
king also this is another opportunity
another instructional moment here where
white now has the option to pick up that
d7 pawn
why not why not take that d7 pun let's
have a look if rook takes d7 here there
can follow queen a4 and after the rook
reacts to the threat there's now rook to
d8 what is happening here
white regained the material but because
that D pawn is no longer around black is
able to now exchange what was a very
passive rook on e85 for this active
piece that's one of the downsides with
winning upon in this position it's that
you release these passive rooks these
rooks are not contributing taking the
pawn allows the rooks to contribute
white presses with h4 this is a very
nice way to break down the king position
a lot of pressure on g6 sacrifices on g6
are close by so as an example as an
example if this Queen just tries to go
into the vacuum cleaner mode taking on a
- ignoring this h5 idea taking on B -
here we go chop chop chop chop chop a
lot of chops and in the end this is a
winning attack for team black this is
serious this sacrifice on g6 Queen takes
here the bishop sneaks in mate and six
came here mate
okay the Queen can't just you know go
into pacman mode has to do something
about this idea
Queen a5 is looking to scoop up this
pawn two moves hitting with Czech Queen
take z5 what is white dill
stops the Queen from pivoting on a1
altogether black tries to get at this
pawn one way or the other
c4 is interesting right it opens up the
Queen's eyes but another way to view
this move c4 is that it reduces the
quality of the e6 9 now why do I say
this
well it's because with the pawn on c5
that connects really well with the night
there's this really nice Knight to d4
move that can show up in many variations
but now this is no longer you know it
doesn't have that support with c4 on
board so rook d5 in the game need to
defend that point Queen now slips in
there's one very active piece for stock
fish 8 King G - the cotan the Queen is
that piece that's active so King G to c3
some exchanges here on the Queen side
and now h5 to be expected
breaking down the g6 point rookie 7 is
prepared to add some lateral defense so
for example if captures like this
there's a recapture also the rook is
defending d7 as things are changing here
you know there are plenty of other
situations where capturing d7 could turn
out to be quite good this is this is
getting to be one of those points so you
can't just give up this pawn in this
position rookie 7 is there to defend and
now a bit of a reposition here with the
bishop where would you like to have that
bishop by dealing b3 nice secure square
defended by the pawn and him and
opposite that King one piece one way or
the other will be pinned to the king so
Queen e1 in the game Bishop b3 rook da
we're having a bit of a reorganization
at this stage rook f3 Black has defended
well against this idea to capture and
you know the rook is there this is a
pretty strong defender against the
seventh ranked squares so the pieces are
repositioning to more central locations
and I really like this next move Queen
to d2 what is this doing exactly it's
allowing this pawn to become a great
thorn in black side I believe the first
piece that occupied the h6 square in
this game was a bishop next we had the
Queen and now we're going to have a pawn
notice those three pieces I just
mentioned what do they do well they
control the g7 square they take away
this key flight square from the King
this allows for plenty of different back
rank mating ideas so the Queen drops
back D to h6 right around the corner and
you know you want to do more with the
Queen right you want to do two and two
or more aggressive things if possible
well here's one aggressive thing there's
some pressure against d7 it's not just
about clearing the way for h6 Queen g4
in the game Bishop d1 questioning the
rook are questioning the Queen post if
Queen takes pawn there's rook takes f7
Queenie for staying central there is a
pin there h6 on board so now black needs
to be on the lookout for back rank mates
flight squares taken away from the King
this is a strong strong on Knight c7
rook d6 it seems like this pawn could be
one that's not true if Queen takes pawn
in this position rook III and then
for distract the Queen from defending
the rook white would win and if rook
takes pawn there's a problem there
this d7 pond that has been ignored a
couple times will be ignored no more
white could smash through here and
there's just all sorts of stuff
happening many back ranked squares being
observed by the White Queen pressure on
f7 and eventually white would be able to
force black into a giant ball something
like this taking advantage of pins and
something like this and black would be
dead this would be a cool way to see the
game end straight to me okay
the idea here don't take on e5 with
either piece or you're in big trouble 96
in the game Bishop b3 gives up the e5
pawn Queen takes e5 white is down two
pawns at this point but has really good
pieces if you do a real comparison all
the white pieces are better okay maybe
maybe maybe not the Queen both rooks
both white rooks are better than the
black rooks the bishop is better than
the knight the white King is more secure
than the black King if there's any piece
that's better that black has it's the
Queen it's in the center but it's the
only active piece that black has and
this post is immediately brought into
question rook d5 surprisingly enough the
Queen doesn't have many good options
here if Queen to e4 in this position it
seems appealing stays in the center puts
white in a pin but it allows Queen to c3
and this is something that black should
not allow to even allow the the White
Queen to patrol this dark diagonal and
coordinate well with this thorn pawn
this place is a restriction on the night
and this Knight is not stable could be
knocked out and may is close by so the
Queen needs to make a move where she
keeps control over g7 she has a couple
options one is a1 and the others h8
if the Queen goes to a-1 she could kind
of be cut out of the game with rooks III
it's surprising move but the Queen now
is kind of without a good square she
only has b1 available and that could
maybe be taken away and just a little
bit she's very short on squares if she
goes to a-1 she's vulnerable to attack
so in this game black decides on Queen
h8 ensuring that the Queen will be able
to observe g7 directly and you can't get
out the Queen you can't attack the Queen
so what does alpha zero do next
hits black where they're a little bit
vulnerable Queen before rook is under
fire Knight c5 and I haven't thrown any
pop quiz any pop quizzes your way here's
one for you right now
alpha zero to move of white to move what
would you do in this position feel free
to pause the video okay alpha zero goes
with an exchange sacrifice takes out the
night and this Bishop without the knight
on e6 increases in value does a
wonderful job
interacting with the rook and more than
that we have this deeper idea Queen h4
insisting I'm striking at them striking
at that rook and one more detail and
that is the follow-up move after the
rook is defended rook f6 do you see what
just happened with this last move Black
has killed both king and queen the two
most valuable pieces that black has are
now dead by the rook and the pond okay
the Queen also factors into this
equation Queen is necessary to defend
the rook but that job will soon be
transitioned to the pump the pawn will
have that role to defend that rook
it's gonna run up to g5 and the Queen
will be free to do whatever she wants
black is in a giant pickle can't get out
of it black at this stage is now down to
making pond moves just back and forth
moves there is no rescuing this cornered
Queen rook f8 in the game
pressure is on f7 with all white pieces
three attackers three defenders must
remain on this point black is down to
just pawn moves basically or you know
this pawn is going to have to move
before this rook can move a5 in the game
g4 d5 could just take that rip d7 Bishop
c4
and from here we have a four in the game
this is an interesting moment I would
have liked to have seen this this game
end there's a cool variation here
instead of a four if rook d4 is played
pop quiz what would you do as white feel
free to pause the video white would have
this winning shot if Rick d4 was played
white would have rook takes f7 this
would but would have been a beautiful
finish rook takes Queen and rook g7
that's a double check and mate notice
the power wants more of this thorn pawn
in the game we have a four this rook is
now super glued in there on f6
seven points are restricting the king
and queen continuing we have a three a
nice dropping back here Queen f3
maintaining pressure on f7 ready to pick
up the pawn and one other key detail
sneaking into c6 is pretty deadly in the
game we have rook c7 defending and white
simply picks up the pawn what if black
defends the pawn well Queen c6 you see
the threat what would you do as white
after the move rook to e7 feel free to
pause the video okay white would have
another spectacular shot rook takes g7
pawn takes rook Queen takes pawn don't
try to take the Queen there's a pin and
mate once more that pawn on h6 deadly
rook c7 in the game there goes the a
pond and stock fish just gives up the
Queen for the rook at this stage you
know I guess this is the best way to
prolong the game here giving up the
Queen for the rook if you don't do that
it's just a lot of back-and-forth with
the rook the Queen could return the pawn
can bolt so the Queen just gives up
herself for the the rook at this stage
and we just get a few more moves in here
and after a four stockfish eight resigns
the evaluation is off the charts at the
moment it's reading me in 14 May 13 now
main 12 I think it gets down to me and
maintenance
anyhow there's just nothing to do here
for stockfish one of the rooks always
has to watch out for the back rank and
another rope has to watch out for a
sacrifice on f7 so as an example rook a7
a5 you know if you take this pawn
there's a shot like this chop check and
checkmate so if this did continue we had
maybe something like this there's even
something fancy like Bishop to be 7 and
then Queen to b6 this rook is dead so
plenty of different ways to proceed at
this stage but this is where stockfish
eight resigns after this move sixty a
four so what more to add with this one
stop it you underestimate the value of
for us in proximity to your king
you